foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
okay
foreign
thank you
foreign
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude he is gone ladies and
gentlemen Alex Jones is now very very
upset with me look at look that is a
freaking prefer right there he thinks
he's smarter than you think she's better
than you and he's gonna beat you Pac-Man
never talked to the new world war
because Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude is gone
[Music]
[Music]
right there who thinks he's smarter than
you and she's better than you and he's
gonna beat you
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed it is Trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way extra points if you can sample Trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
multiple times that it was massive dumps
that led him to lose the election which
is just on another level
where the water rushes out to see
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to Once dumps
[Music]
what is going on here what is go what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
past the election
what is going on here what is the what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here
Pizza
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets
15 times
[Music]
[Music]
15 times
some bathrooms what on Earth is going on
with Trump toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation the big mess of dumps
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms well
welcome everybody we are awaiting the
failed former president Donald Trump in
a particularly consequential Saturday
evening rally right side broadcasting is
covering it on Newsmax is covering it
but right now even though they're
against indoctrinating children they're
selling the Trump guide for kids which
is uh which is quite a scene if I do say
so myself and let's just get
our shot here properly set up so that we
don't have any issues later I always
like to do this only the best for those
in my audience let's just see if we can
get that
perfectly squared away there we go
and over here
and I think that that's just about right
yeah there we go
and then we'll make it a little bit
bigger there we go ladies and Gentlemen
please
please and then I think I just need to
move it
is it here no we want it down here
beautiful okay we are very very much
ready this is a rally just days quite
frankly days before the 2022 midterm
elections in Texas now Texas is a very
important race it's the race for
governor and that is Beto uh hold on
let's make sure we're playing this let
me just refresh to make sure we've got
the right feed
I don't want even a second delay for my
audience there we go and let's make sure
we have audio
we do
um
Beto versus Greg Abbott and other
important races as well in Texas so a
very very consequential race now you all
know that I don't say things on the show
that are reflective of the way I wish
them to be
and couch it as the way they are what I
mean by that is I'll tell you here's how
I want things to be
and here's how things really are I will
never mix up the two and while I would
love to be able to say to you that
Democrats are looking absolutely
fantastic for the midterm elections
Democrats are looking increasingly
terrible for the midterm elections and
in fact if we look at the latest updates
from the 538 forecasts you will see that
in the house Democrats are down to a 19
chance of winning and you will see here
that that is declined dramatically in
the last few days of the inflection
point coming you know in late September
uh Republican chances improving
Democratic chances increasingly in the
toilet they've been flushed two or three
times so far not yet 10 to 15 but we'll
see kind of how that turns out even in
the Senate where Democrats have been
long favored to keep control of the
Senate it is barely a coin flip at this
point in time Democrats now down to a 55
55 percent chance of holding the Senate
um and as you can see a very similar
inflection point now to what do we
attribute this one element I believe is
not the unfortunate the timing of the
Roe v Wade overturning
was not perfect for Democrats in the
sense that really you would want the
election to be to happen right here it's
sort of like if you take an energy drink
do you you know how the kids these days
take energy drinks it that you know it's
like um
um they take the like red pigs and all
these different drinks that people take
um you want the full power of the energy
drink at the critical moment right
imagine that you want it for some kind
of go-kart race I don't know and
it hits its its full power and you're
still like walking over to your car
you've it's wasted you understand what
I'm saying right do people know what I'm
saying
it seems as though the timing of uh Roe
v Wade being overturned which was not up
to Democrats it was the Supreme Court
it's on their schedule
it helped Democrats and now the impact
is fading
that I believe is one aspect to this
um in addition to that
Republican messaging as absurdly
pathetic as it is
has to some degree worked you know the
the anti-biden stuff and all it it's
shaping up to be potentially disastrous
we just don't yet know but we are we are
looking at all of it very strongly okay
another important story tonight
oh god there are so many people who are
going to end up bad banned today
oh boy listen I mean well it's free to
ban people so it's not like we're going
to run out but
it's a little bit depressing yeah let me
just I I want to let me just mention one
thing okay and I'm not saying this
for any particular reason other than to
tell you about something
the amount of overt anti-semitic
messages that have popped up in my email
YouTube comments
twitch comments Facebook voicemails
since the Kanye West public
anti-Semitism explosion
has been stunning now I always get a lot
of anti-Semitic messages
but it's exploded and it's it's what I
call the Trump effect Kanye coming out
and saying basically every anti-semitic
Trope under the sun
it doesn't create anti-semitism
maybe it does but the main point of it
is or the main effect is
it allows the anti-semites to be way
more comfortable
publicly announcing their anti-semitism
it's very similar to what you know I
don't think Trump created racist it's
not like there were all these people
sitting around with no negative
preconceived notions about Mexicans and
Trump comes down the escalator and goes
there's all these Mexican rapists and
people go I never thought about that
before yeah I'm on the Mexican rapist no
they they of course already thought
about it but Trump made them more
comfortable
being public about those views anyway I
think it's the same thing with the Kanye
anti-Semitism thing
um and it's it's vile it's vile okay so
anyway long story short there's going to
be a lot of people getting banned today
I can already tell it's just like it's
in the air the same way that fall is in
the air uh and you know ripening
ripening leaves and apple cider and and
uh pumpkins and all these different
things pumpkin spice all that stuff
bands are in the air as well I can just
tell okay a few super chats Cody says
the voice you did mocking Kyle
rittenhouse's co-host made me tear up
from laughing so hard I thought he was
suing all media anyhow yeah I know yeah
the guy who was Kyle rittenhouse's
co-host I don't know how many of you
have seen let's actually pull it up hold
on
Kyle Rittenhouse YouTube I actually want
to see if he has
new uh any new content
let's see no this isn't it where is it
Kyle Rittenhouse
ah here it is no he still has just been
one you have to see this this is just
unbelievable check this out
hey guys thank you guys for checking out
my YouTube channel I have some great
content that I look forward to making
for you guys he has great content that
he looks forward to making
did you make it or are you going to make
it what are you talking about thank you
Brandon for helping me get started for
uh listen to this guy with you and
giving me some great advice so uh I
don't know if it's great advice yet
we'll see how the channel goes it is
advice it is advice let's see how the
channel goes first Kyle over to you Jim
who's next on The Price is Right advice
we don't know if it's quite great yeah
guys I don't I don't know that I'd call
it great yet but it is advice Brandon
back to you let's go
yeah we'll we'll see we'll see but we'll
see about that advice Kyle thank you you
guys can help him out by going ahead and
liking this video yeah don't like the
video do not comment okay thank you very
much let's move on all right
um what else do we have the Roe v Wade
effect will not be obvious in polls in
critical States simply because of how
socially dangerous it is to voice your
support for women's Choice people are
quietly mad let's wait and see Fair
Point uh I appreciate that okay huge
thank you ladies and gentlemen to Alan
Morris who just signed up on my website
thank you so much you are new member
number one today folks the the goal is
very modest tonight it's only 100. I
want to say thanks to liquid ice hatch
for short Margot Cabot and Cody the
epilepsy Dragon for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at five and if
you're just joining us the word of the
day
is indict that's also the coupon code
today which you can use at
joinpakman.com all right another story
of today's rally is that it is the
return of Donald Trump's plane now
there we go do I care about Trump's
plane in a direct sense no I don't care
about Trump's plane at all but it is
expensive to get a dilapidated gaudy
plane back up and running and Trump has
spent a lot of time and money doing that
and that is a signal
potentially about 2024. would he spend
all this money given how cheap Trump is
on a plane when he can just keep using
other people's planes as Charters as
he's been doing maybe not okay maybe not
and uh it does appear that it is on
route to Texas or he may have already
arrived this is the back of the Trump
plane and Dan scavino his social media
manager posting about it so that will be
another thing and we're watching all of
it very very closely
um right side broadcasting has it and
Newsmax has it although Newsmax
sometimes has not taken the speeches I
believe they are taking uh the speeches
today
so that's another story maybe a plane
that at some point uh Trump will need to
flee the country we don't really know
all right now I do want to mention that
former Democrat and the last true
liberal the last true Centrist the last
true critical thinker Tulsi gabbard
spoke at one of these
um anti-trans rallies now I know guys I
know this is a total shock to everybody
in the audience I know I know that
there's not a single one of you who
would have thought oh within days of
leaving the Democratic party Tulsi would
be propping up the most extreme elements
of the right wing movement including
Carrie Lake if you can imagine and then
the rally to end child mutilation
let's listen to just a few moments here
from Tulsi who remember a lot of
progressives so-called back in 2020 were
saying this is the only actual
Progressive
[Applause]
thank you aloha
thanks to all of you who have gathered
here today on such an important issue as
We Gather here this year we're
celebrating the 50th anniversary of the
enactment of Title IX
[Applause]
Title IX was created as of out of a
record by the way audience doesn't give
two shits what she says it's just she's
now here she's on our side
etc etc they could you think the
audience cares or knows about Title IX
give me a break guys definition of the
biological difference the between men
and women
have had great opportunity and
advancement because God that crowd he's
like
we are here because of the 1964 Civil
Rights man and we are not going to be
hold on I'm coming talk it just you
can't hear anything because of it
where we are now today though is those
in power denying the existence of women
they are seeking to erase us as an
entire category of people what an even
more dangerously they are denying the
existence of objective truth
without recognition that there is such a
thing as truth
There Are No Boundaries in our society
which is why we are where we are what a
terrible speech I mean just just a
horrible horrible horrible speech thanks
to brain matter and irie man for the
twitch Prime subscriptions number six
and seven do you guys want to listen to
more of this or maybe a different
speaker I don't even know who else spoke
let's see
who's this
no idea
no clue
same person again
no clue
no idea
no clue
now I have no idea who these people are
huh
we're done all right all right yeah
that's fine we can we can get away from
it it's it's totally fine
so that was the rally to end child
mutilation all right well
sounds like a worthy cause I don't know
that's another thing they always choose
these like Anodyne banal not banal but
sort of like
titles where it's like who could
possibly against that it be against that
you know it'll be like this is the rally
to end cold-blooded murder and it's like
wow cold-blooded murder sounds bad I
mean I guess I guess I'm against it and
like it's a horrible anti-abortion rally
you know
um That's a classic move
I mean quite frankly that's that's how
they do all their framing right they go
we need tax relief oh well
if the word relief is there it must be a
burden that you can be relieved from
taxes must be bad and get rid of all
taxes
you have to kind of hand it to them
they're pretty good with that stuff
they're genuinely pretty good with that
stuff sir most of my machines can handle
a class action lawsuit says Matt via
super chat but there are a couple I've
concerned I'm concerned couldn't is
pillow willing to negotiate yeah we got
to get pillow back on the show
we need some answers about those
machines
um do I have my machine clip here hold
on I'm coming wait that's not it hold on
where is it further scream that his days
are numbered
[Applause]
God that's not it here it is over 54
countries have now been taken by the
machines yep
that has happened
um you guys want to see pure comedy
this you are not going to believe by the
way very windy I don't know if Trump's
hair piece will stay on that's that's
crazy
uh okay let's go to this is beyond
parody Herschel Walker has advice okay
if you have a child with a woman
even if you leave the woman you don't
leave the child
it's not clear Herschel Walker knows how
many kids he has and this is the advice
he's giving other people how do you
write this stuff
and let's become fathers of those
fatherless child right meaning let's try
to direct them in the right way yeah
yeah
well what can I just say this here okay
so you to raise your child now you got
to go and try to be he kind of hasn't in
fact he's an absent father for multiple
kids it's like how you know I would
understand ignoring this topic
altogether but the right is so
delusional that he can actually come in
and go we got to be fathers to you know
we we can't be absent fathers dude
you're an absent father your father to
somebody else what about teaching our
black men that if you lay down with a
woman and you make a baby it is your
responsibility to stay there to make
sure that that child is raised well
that's what I'm talking about give them
good values that you have right you say
you know what and I said this is someone
else if you have a child with a womb
even if you have to leave that woman
even if you ever leave that woman you
don't leave the child right right but
why did you do that then why why did you
leave all these kids and you're you're
an absent father to all these kids you
let that child know you try to work it
out you're going to be respectful to her
and you're going to be respectable right
like sending 700 for an abortion to
other things you show that to your child
man it's unbelievable let's see RCP
Walker Warnock let's see how the polling
is doing
Warnock geez that is really tight oh my
God Walker might win this is this
I may have to move to Canada I really
might not I I've I that's a joke I've
said so many times how silly that is
it's very difficult to move to Canada
obviously my choices are are Argentina
or Israel those are the chances the the
the options that I have at this point in
time
all right so that's pretty horrible
pretty horrible David How likely do you
think it is Trump is charged after the
election I've been thinking it's looking
more likely than not I agree with that
actually I agree with that
happy Saturday David do we have an under
over for Trump's start today well the
weather is making me doubt let's see if
they're discussing the weather as no
friend to president Trump and your kids
are hearing the lies on social media and
even in the classroom but Mike Huckabee
thinks that kids deserve to know that
yeah okay so I don't know honestly at
this point
let me know in the chat how many minutes
late Will trump be let me know what you
think
uh oh we got a hype train going on uh
twitch or no it might be over we might
have missed it you had you had me
laughing a ton hello from Worcester
student at HC uh must be Holy Cross
beautiful beautiful I want to say thank
you to you cousisto
I hope I pronounced that correctly dear
God otherwise I apologize who just
signed up on my website using the coupon
code Obama Obama you were new member
number eight today ladies and gentlemen
I should do the guy the voice of the guy
on the Kyle Rittenhouse Channel ladies
and gentlemen ladies and gentlemen if
you're just joining me now if you're if
you are just joining us uh it is not the
Rapture on your screen it's just gotten
very dark and windy at the Texas rally
for Trump
and I have a declaration to make I am
coming to you today with tears in my
eyes to say forget about the my pillow
coupon codes forget about
paying Newsmax for a trump gold coin
forget about all of it consider
supporting truly Community funded media
by getting a membership on my website I
would just love it if you did that you
can go to joinpakman.com it's so easy
even the people at this rally can do it
quite frankly okay
joinpakman.com I say yearly but you can
do either okay either is welcome you hit
the sign up button okay you type in the
coupon code see above my head where it
says indict
you type in indict price goes absolutely
criminally low you say David sir that
price is so high it makes me cry then
instead of that you type in Obama okay
and then the price will be so low that
it'll make you cry and every single
person who signs up there I will thank
to the extent that I am able oh my God
and they are dumping in Here Andrew AVR
drums has just gifted three
subscriptions on the website putting us
at 11 for the day
uh very much appreciate that okay couple
other uh guys please don't report the
discounts I see people saying you're
going to report the discounts please
don't do that
okay thank you
um I do want to get to a couple of other
things let's get to some videos from uh
I really like to set the scene at these
rallies okay
um and let's see some of the things that
we have going on
stuff to scroll to the right spots here
uh oh this was earlier here was Texas
lieutenant governor Dan Patrick with a
very strong declaration
[Applause]
for Beto votes against me votes against
Ken Paxton and all the way down the
ballot that sounds pretty good that's
but more of a reason to uh
that's that makes me more interested in
voting for Beto that's why it is so
important
to get everyone you know to vote every
Republican all the way does Dan Patrick
look a little bit like Mrs Doubtfire is
that does anybody else see that he has a
very strange look his politics are
toilet politics right I mean I don't
care he could look like Bea Arthur and
I'd vote for him if his politics were
good but is there a bit of a Mrs
Doubtfire look there
people agree
okay anyway let's continue
um here is Ronnie Jackson making medical
claims I think I'm one of the few people
that have the background where I can
speak intelligently about this I know
what it takes physically and mentally to
be the president United States and I'm
here to tell you today I'm making a
medical determination Joseph Biden does
not have what it takes to be our
president whoa
cool
whoa
thank you to Chewie for gifting five
subscriptions on YouTubes putting us at
16 out of a hundred very very much
appreciate that that actually it means a
lot Christopher says did you get the
pillows from Mike the Tasmanian devil
yes so during my interview with Mike
pillow he he like swore up and down that
he was going to send me some of his my
pillow stuff that his assistant would
reach out didn't send me a damn thing
didn't send me a damn thing had he sent
them to me I would absolutely try the
pillows and I would tell you it's a good
pillow or it's not a good pillow but he
is not sending it
um
here's Ronnie going crazy
[Music]
for the healthiest president that's ever
lived Donald J Trump
[Applause]
where I was the physician for the
healthiest president that's ever lived
Donald J Trump
oh my God these people are bonkers
hey you know can I mention something
that I see as a trend on Twitch and
YouTube that's just so silly anytime a
song plays you see all these people
going oh dmca copyrighted music quick
quick turn it down
it's not like a huge deal anymore
um
like worst case is for the VOD you have
to share Revenue with the owner of the
copyright like it's not it's not a big
deal I don't know if it's weird to me
that this hasn't gotten around where
people don't realize it but it's like
it's not a huge deal you know it
man
hey David I live in Texas it's very
windy some fire watches and high
allergies it'll be a short speech and
you might need to wear a hat yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
no that's are they starting up with the
stuff
oh my God okay
um wow I want to say thank you to
Mackenzie Stewart who just signed up on
my website with the coupon code Obama
Obama
Mackenzie you were new member number 17.
also want to say thanks to Denise Gammon
and Kevin Ram new members number 18 and
19. folks let's do a little something
okay because it's a slow night new
member number 25 tonight I will send you
a free item from my online store to
anywhere in the world the coffee mug the
tea mug the whiskey mug the soda mug
I'll send any of those items or a
t-shirt a hat a hoodie whatever okay new
member number 25 now
I understand that you have choices in
coupon codes right on the screen you
could be getting my pillow items using
right side broadcasting Network's coupon
code
that seems pretty depressing
seems appalling in fact or you could be
using the great coupon code Obama on my
website and we all have a much better
time
I know you have choices when it comes to
coupon codes trust me I do trust me I do
uh disappointed to see you're still
running coupon codes that are clearly
illegal Charlie they can take my coupon
codes from me over my cold dead hands
how about that
thanks to lilu and the Portland report
for the twitch Prime subscriptions Trump
is supposed to start three minutes ago
he was supposed to start three minutes
ago his plane appeared to land about 20
minutes ago and it is extraordinarily
windy
um so we will see
we'll see what they're able to do with
that we'll see what they're able to do
thanks to hatch for short
for gifting a subscription
also thanks to Rolando alaniz for the
website membership at 23 Folks at 25 I'm
giving out a free item from my store
whoever's number 25 whatever you want
you can get the hoodie you can get the
baseball hat you can get whatever you
want number 25 couple voicemails I know
that we don't have a long time but let's
listen to a couple of voicemails
so I called Ben and Jerry's because I
just I have to do some investigating
um I wanted to ask them what is White
Privilege like from this perspective of
somebody whose owner why would Ben and
Jerry's know about white privilege she
went to jail and then bragged about it
on the media I was wondering what's
different about you and the black people
what would White Privilege be and why
would that be so special and she said oh
well it's not appropriate for you to ask
me what race I am so from now on I'm
gonna tell people it's inappropriate for
you to tell me what race you are okay
well Whitney very strong declaration
Danny dumping in a Super Chat what's a
Saturday night without a trump rally and
David packman's commentary keep up the
good work sir you Farren and Luke are
all great peeps well thank you Danny I
very much appreciate that
um let's see if we can find a bit of a
more
um
like tone down voicemail
I guess I would say
um
let's see
David I have some serious questions
about this Alex challenge thing the more
I think about the fact that he's about
to lose like a billion dollars what is
he gonna do like get on a payment plan
like he's not gonna be able to pay it so
what happens to somebody when they have
negative a billion dollars they got to
pay out to all these people check out my
interview with the plaintiff's attorney
who got the first 50 million dollar
settlement against Alex Jones check that
out and then you will he explains the
issues and ways that
um they have a figuring out how much
money is there really and of course how
to collect it anybody can just get a
settlement the question is can you
collect the money let's listen to Mike
pillow joining right side broadcasting
is this Glenn Greenwald doing the
interviewing it's a very Glenn Greenwald
look you know I come from a past where
you know I've been in every walks of
life you know from North Forks to Fort
forks and then that's the American dream
everybody and to lose the American dream
that's right we're up against Sherry
this is a spiritual Battle of Good and
Evil and all you feel these are that's
the most amazing thing these rallies
yeah it's just anybody out there that
would be you can't help but be inspired
you know and maybe you know you really
can help but be inspired by these
rallies good morning you get up to the
morning time you go to bed fight the
media
speaking of research can you talk to us
about Flashpoint the other day uh
president Trump on Truth social uh
posted something where I guess it was a
preacher at the top at the at the stage
said and what do you all think about
President Trump and the entire Arena
right the entire Earth
and waving flags and you were there
weren't you absolutely and you know what
the churches they need to get behind if
you're a pastor out there you better get
behind it you know literally against
non-profit IRS law like what he's saying
is he's telling every Church to break
the law that allows them to not pay
taxes by not doing politics our country
the the churches the pastors have to
speak out it can't be living inside can
you imagine this is a time of Courage
you can't courage is contagious and you
can't save it for a rainy day I said
that before 100 no we got to speak out
but the whole church pretty good
argument to tax every single Church
isn't it three one way yes that's what
the people want Donald Trump is Hope and
he's proven he's proven what you know
the stuff he did problem solution and
what it would manifest to to help all
people not just the Republicans that's
really how I feel about the Trump
presidency that's my memory it was
problem and then immediately Solution
that's that's exactly right uh wow all
right I want to say thank you to David
Latham who is new member number 24 and
winning the free item today is Devin
cuttier Devin cuddier you were new
member number 25 email info
davidpackman.com and we'll get you your
free item also thanks to Gustavo Castro
Giovanna Lanza and Elizabeth bugliarello
um new members 26 27 and 28.
uh also thanks to Jay bambian
new member number 29 and over on Twitch
Titan Mars Productions and micro Kimmy
uh well I do another free item at 50.
sure
sure
um we're at 31 50 gets a free item I
love it why not uh Elijah O'Connell and
Michael Snyder are new members
um 32 and 33. so we we may actually get
there sooner than later
lies in politics says via Super Chat
keep up the righteous work sir well
thank you sir I appreciate that very
much let's see if we can do uh one more
voicemail or two Sir Mr Pacman I come to
you with my eyes crying I'm I'm
literally crying how did you become the
greatest political commenter there is
I'm literally crying sir well that guy
seemed pretty shaken up
he seemed to overcome with emotion
um
are we back on Tick Tock oh yeah let me
mention this by the way tick tocks
we are back on tick tock and we were
initially banned for coveted
disinformation and election
disinformation of course we were
debunking the dis you guys know we
appealed it the first appeal was
rejected because we violated the
Integrity policy of tick tocks if you
can imagine okay
we then appealed it again
and then we were told the the ban is
upheld because you post nudity
and we were like we've never posted
nudity we've never posted nudity we
appealed again and then with no
explanation it was just back up it was
open again The Tick Tock account was
open now I have to tell you something
we have as many of you know famously
1.5 million YouTube subscribers
and we have 200
000 or so Tick Tock followers okay so
it's like this
I am now getting recognized
overwhelmingly more
from people who say I see you on tick
tock
than people who watch on YouTube
I don't know what it is about Tick Tock
but almost I would say
I would say four out of five people who
say hello to me in public now
say I found you on Tick Tock or I watch
you on tick tock I don't understand what
it is we have a fraction of the
followers there does anyone recognize me
from twitch nobody recognizes me from
twitch we have 92 000 followers on
Twitch almost 93 000 no one has ever
recognized me from twitch that I can
tell you for sure
uh okay other super chats coming in sir
how many truths have been told on Truth
social not many
not many
seems like the worse the Scandal the
more pathetic the debate performance the
better the poll numbers for Republican
candidates what's up with that it's
backwards it truly is
hi I'd love to see you cover the forward
party more maybe in a more positive
manner I think they're doing good work
no I mean listen I've already covered it
it's not interesting to me a party
between the Democratic and Republican
parties isn't interesting it's to the
right of the democratic party I'm to the
left of the democratic party I think
there's very little that's interesting
to me about the forward party I don't
have anything more that it's interesting
because the suggestion is cover the
forward party more but say good things
about it well I don't have good things
to say about it
I don't know I mean that Andrew Yang is
welcome back on the show anytime I can
say that
all right uh thanks to Rich Gould Corey
Barton Crystal Bailey and Tyler Jackson
for the website memberships putting us
at 37 next free item is at 50. folks we
are at 37 at 50. I give away another
free item from my online store
it is a great day to do it can you use a
coupon code and still get a free item
absolutely
absolutely folks this is genuinely a
free item so on the website like the
code Obama saves you money the code we
have another code sad Trump which you
can use that one oh wow sad Trump seems
to be the best code actually
uh even with a code
number 50 will still get a free item yes
um okay
another voicemail
let's see what I have a lot of these
voicemails are very much not good
not good
let me see
hello David
um I don't want display on the air stuff
okay all right the the voicemails are
only to be played on air it's never
going to get listened to unfortunately I
like I don't have time to listen to them
just for personal edification so if you
don't want it played on air
unfortunately
it's uh it's over let's listen to
another one
hi David
um I don't know why everyone's so
fascinated with your fast food thing I
just want to uh
I I just want I haven't had fast food uh
my birthday was uh about a week ago that
would have been 12 years I haven't had
fast period so uh yeah not a not a big
deal uh rice and beans totally works
really well I would put protein in there
though uh
yeah I I just thought I just don't
understand I I guess I wanna like well I
guess people eat fast food because it's
it's really cheap but it's really gross
like yeah I don't even know that fast
food is really that cheap I have to say
I mean it some of these places quite
frankly don't seem that cheap to me
let's see Subway sandwich prices what
does subway cost
Subway sandwiches are some of them are
11 yeah I mean it's
it's not that cheap right I mean I don't
know oh and it's more in cities that's
oh okay interesting yeah I don't know I
don't know yeah but all right well in
any case everybody just relax
everything's fine I I haven't had fast
food in 20 years and I'm fine I've
somehow made it thanks to Sunny place
for the website membership you are
number 38 today I appreciate that
um well I cover the verdict in the Daryl
Brooks trial I would love to yeah I've
been watching it personally and it is
wild it is wild wild
um
other voicemails let's see
what else we have oh it looks like
Trump's coming out soon actually I gotta
thank my girlfriend for that but anyway
because we were at we were at a rally
all right
um okay so anyway Trump's gonna speak
soon he I guess flew in on his his plane
it's refurbished it's all it's all crazy
David sir if Biden's policies are
gazpacho would Trump be soup Nazis
Seinfeld joke for those unaware nicely
done Stephen very very nicely done I
must say
that was that was actually pretty good
thank you to Amanda Abbott for the
website membership you're number 39
do a free item at 40. all right fine
let's do this next free item is at 45
instead of 50. okay new member number 45
gets to pick something from my online
store and we'll send it to you
absolutely for free and I will
personally package it up and tape up the
box now I can't do that we don't
things are everything's made like it's
they're made as orders come in so I
actually can't do that yes people
noticing the weather looks very
problematic here in Texas extremely
windy
um should make it more interesting
um it breaks my heart you never
responded to my question not today
regarding the casting of Glenn Howerton
as David packman in your bio epic let's
see who is Glenn Howerton
Glenn Howerton
okay that's interesting I mean the guy's
like 10 years older than me but I guess
yeah that's not bad I I'd be up for this
guy playing me in a movie about me sure
why not
hmm
what do people think would be better
for someone to play me in the biopic of
my inevitable fall from grace that will
be coming soon
should it be this guy should it be the
guy who played Mr shoe on glad on uh
Glee what's the name of the show Glee
the singing show Mr shoe on Glee
or
um
Joseph Gordon-Levitt
what do you guys think
Glenn Howerton for sure
Jake Gyllenhaal no not that doesn't make
sense
Joseph Gordon-Levitt
yeah no I mean listen I would be honored
to be played by any of these great
actors really
uh Trump signs are coming down here in
Wisconsin people told me Biden gave the
IRS billions to go away Trump supporters
with signs
I don't know anymore I'm not sure I know
what you mean Matt but it sounds sounds
pretty crazy
um all right it looks like they're
starting like a hype video for Trump of
some kind
um here's Trump's uh Soviet Style
uh
Soviet style press secretary or right
who even knows what her title is at this
point in time thanks to maximum lean for
the twitch Prime subscription you were
number 40. also thank you to Terry
Malone Bill Dickhouse Sean Thibodeau and
Tara canwell folks that's 44. the next
person to get a membership on my website
gets the free item
hat hoodie t-shirt coffee mug whatever
you want
wind that could chill the blowns says
Daniel indeed
indeed indeed indeed let's see if we can
sneak in another voicemail here
the Texas rally
no other time would I want to be a 747
pilot and a skydiver at the same time oh
oh boy
that's pretty dark that is pretty dark I
have to say
uh
uh let's see what else we've got
hey you gave me back man
um I'm wondering why have you not done a
video about Athen Klein oh give me a
break Ethan Klein Troy get the hell out
of here
uh that's just that's just absurd that's
absurd Ethan Klein got
Troy is such a boar
he's really such a boar it's sad he used
to be funny at one point like 10 years
ago all right thank you to Vance white
Vance you were new member 45 today you
get a free item on my online store
please email info davidpackman.com David
farrugia and Tyler Jackson also with the
memberships putting us at 47
Shelly Riley putting us at 48 via twitch
Prime
let's go for 50. I will give away an
item at 50. we are currently at 48 new
member number 50 on the website gets a
free item absolutely Trump imminently
speaking
the atmosphere just electric at the
rally as you can tell insane
[Music]
right here in Texas really great and I
think the energy is actually good for an
outdoor rally like outdoor rallies are
great here we go step aside the 45th
president United States Donald J Trump
uh all right thanks to Kevin Kirkpatrick
for the website membership your new
member number 49. folks next person
literally at the stroke of trump coming
out and we will all been men next member
gets that free item from the store it is
it is going to be wild wild stuff
is Trump even coming out what's going on
oh god there he is
is it just me or is there absolutely
terrible lighting at this event
are Trump's legs collapsing inward do
you guys see that
I have never noticed that before
his legs his thighs and calves are
forming like the letter x
is there a name for that condition what
on Earth I have never noticed that
before
that is very strange
it's the opposite of bow-legged
knocknead is that that really what it's
called being knockneed
that doesn't sound quite right
I don't know about that
what a bizarre bizarre series of events
the lighting is crazy is the lighting
better on Newsmax oh okay yeah it's sort
of better we'll we'll stick with Newsmax
for the time being
uh
because otherwise I think we might we
might end up screwed quite frankly I
want to say thank you to Kathleen May
Kathleen you our new member number 50
and you get a free item from my online
store please email info davidpackman.com
to collect your winnings also thanks to
chat bot Brian Redskins and T streets
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 53 with uh president Trump
the former failed president important to
mention
about to speak what do people think in
the chat is Trump going to do the
anti-trans line no teacher should be
allowed to teach transgender people were
starting to come whoa whoa whoa and
that's very edgy material very very edgy
material uh
uh what else do I have from Trump here
but he's gonna represent you long and
hard yeah
uh he very well may do it he very well
may do it
uh uh yeah
yes
thank you very much to Rob sound
Robstown
hello two beautiful Corpus Christi thank
you very much what a nice crowd what a
lot of wind
what a lot of wind
thank you very much everybody let's have
a little fun
let's have a little fun we have a bad
subject because you look at what's
happening to our country it's a bad
subject but we're going to make the best
of that and we're going to be stronger
than ever before soon there's happened
to our country is a disgrace but I'm
thrilled to be back with a proud
hard-working American Patriots of the
great state of Texas we love Texas
we ran twice and we won it twice in
landslides I don't know wasting nothing
they say that the Texas going blue
that's not going blue I know it's Trump
it's Trump it's not going blue that I
know of they think it's going blue in
their imaginations and they said that
before our race remember we think Texas
is going blue and then we won in a
landslide they said well we'll have to
use that again the next time but
remember Trump won Texas by the smallest
margin of any Republican in decades and
decades and decades
think of this oh they owe me if I wanted
to do something but I don't do that
because I'm an honest person every
single candidate that I endorse won
their race said that is absolutely
untrue we take it very seriously it's a
very serious thing he just doesn't
mention the ones that lose thank you wow
that's a big crowd back there
but
took a little while for the sound to
catch up
and this November 8th the Maga movement
is going to deliver yet another
texas-sized Landslide we have to we have
no clue
17 days from now the people of Texas are
going to defeat Beto a rock a flag he's
a flake Beto a rock like you know
there's another flake he actually had
the name flake so that was easy
and we're going to keep Greg Abbott a
wonderful man a great man a great
Governor we're going to keep him in the
gun remember when Trump said that
something about Obama's sock draw it's a
tremendous job you're going to re-elect
your absolutely amazing lieutenant
governor man named Dan Patrick has
anyone ever heard of Dan Patrick
where's Dad where is Dan Dan is over
there his son the only person may be
better than him is his son he was U.S
attorney I tell you and Dan's happy to
hear that right somebody else would say
a lousy father oh that's a terrible
thing he said about me no you're happy
right but your son is great and
Brilliant and so are you and thank you
very much Dan Patrick and you know a man
I wish I had him in the white house with
me
re-elect the great Ken Paxton I wish I
had him as
attorney general you're going to vote
for an incredible slate Ken thank you
very much where's Ken by the way I wish
I had you in there for a little wildcard
he's tough he was tough
they would have figured out that voter
fraud in about two minutes yeah it was
obvious what Trump meant was Paxton
maybe would have stolen the election
whereas built William Barden Republicans
up and down the ballot and we're going
to end crazy Nancy Pelosi and she's nuts
she's crazy we're going to end her
political career purpose career is going
to be ended once did you guys notice
that glitch there see Schumer and the
radical democrat congress the Texas way
of life is under siege Biden and the far
left lunatics are Waging War on Texas
energy workers can you believe this
there against oil God and guns and then
they say they're going to do well in
Texas I don't think so
they're crushing your oil and gas shops
imposing massive taxes and restrictions
on the American energy production and
population they're destroying your jobs
and destroying our country and doing it
and strangling American families with
soaring prices we've never had energy
anywhere near these prices we can be the
only ones that when energy oil hits an
all-time high we announce we're not
drilling it's supposed to be the other
way right
energy is hit an all-time high oh good
it's a great time to stop drilling
that's wonderful
water group right let's open up the
borders let millions of people pour in
let convicts prisoners come in from 129
different countries nobody's doing that
they're going to come in from
129 different countries
think of it how stupid can we be how
stupid are these people that are
allowing our country to be ruined
inflation is costing the typical Texas
household nearly 800 every single not
year year would be bad but months how
about that
and that's his stat that's put out by
our governor in fact it's put out by the
federal government so therefore it's
probably much higher
your border has been completely erased
in violent crime in Houston Dallas
Austin and other democrat-run cities is
totally out of control there's only one
way to end this mag this is madness
what's happening to our country is
madness if you support the decline and
fall of America then vote for the
radical left Democrats if you want our
country to fail vote Democrat if you
want to stop the destruction of our
country and save the American dream
which you don't even hear too much but
two years ago you heard about it every
single hour
but if you want to hear about the
American dream and make it come true as
we made it come true just a little while
ago remember
two years ago we had the strongest
Border in the country's history now we
have the worst Border in our history
despite the wall up and down the Slate
vote for Republicans good great
Republicans
there is no more
urgent task for the voters of Texas and
you lead the way I mean you're just an
incredible
group of people you are tough and brave
and brilliant
but for the future of our country than
to
Stop The Invasion you know it's an
invasion just like an army is inviting
us and you have criminals coming in
that's like an army and they they get
their arms if they don't have the arms
they get them real fast but they're
invading our Southern border we had it
stopped
Biden has allowed millions and millions
of illegal aliens a storm across the
border from
160 as of this moment we have the great
Tom home remember two minutes ago he
said it was 129 countries I asked them
how many countries Tom
he actually said 181 we wanted to be
very conservative
160 countries they're storming they're
storming our country they include
they're famously storming our country
from Belgium and all of Africa they're
storming our country they're storming
our borders we have no idea who they are
where they come from
Biden Pelosi the radical Democrats spend
all of their time we have no idea where
they come from
but we have the list of 180 countries
our Nations
but Americans deserve a Congress and a
president who will protect the borders
of our nation
we deserve a government that will defend
our own sovereignty secure our own land
stand up for our own families and
protect the people of our country
it's called a very simple policy America
first you know I watched Biden and some
of the people in his administration how
dare they say America first I said wait
a minute it says America First what's
wrong the greatest is when they say we
will stop Maga I said you know what Maga
means some of them actually don't
know that uh
it means make America great again we
will stop Mega we're gonna stop it
I saw that they said we're gonna stop
Maga we're going to stop the Maga
movement I don't think they know what it
means make America great how do you do
that
even if you want to stop but you just
don't say you want to stop make America
great again even if you do you just say
when you do say do we disagree with the
policies much better we will stop Maga
you hear that doc Ronnie I don't think
you'd say that with Dr karate stand up
doc Rodney we love this guy he said I
was the healthiest president in history
obviously untrue
doc Ronnie he said
Dr Ronnie said I just see him said he's
a handsome guy his wife's actually
better looking and his kids are better
looking than both of them okay
but uh doc Ronnie said I was the
healthiest president in history and in
fact I said hey Ronnie you know they're
trying to say bad things like I'm crazy
like I'm this like I'm that they
actually tried the stupid thing that
didn't last too long hopefully
but I said is there some kind of a test
we can take
which our current president should be
taking but I don't think you're going to
see it oh no
well there is one service and frankly uh
you know it's at Walter Reed which is
incredible by the way an incredible
hospital and you know it's public or it
can be very easily made public you know
in this country they leak all over the
place it's public or it could be made
public or if the Supreme we have to find
the liquor you know how you find the
leaker they'll say oh this is treasonous
what I said so they can't find the
liquor he leaked all about rho v Wade
look this person leaked from the Supreme
Court never happened you know how you
find but they don't want to mention this
because they think it's so terrible you
take the writer because you're never
going to find another going through
phone records this guy's on speed
tonight huh time you take the writer and
or the publisher of the paper a certain
Paper it you know and you say who is the
leaker National Security
and they say we're not going to tell you
they say it's okay you're going to jail
and when this person realizes that he is
going to be
the Bride of another prisoner very
shortly
oh my God he will say I'd very much like
to uh tell you exactly who that leaker
it was Bill Jones I swear he's a liquor
and we got him but they don't want to do
that they don't want to do that but
that's the only way you're going to find
we have to find can you imagine they
leak out of the Supreme Court never
happened a thing like that never
happened before you have to get the
writer and you have to tell the writer
look here's the story The National
Security you have to do this and the
publisher too or the top editors just
think this year more Americans will die
a fentanyl and drug overdose than the
number of Ukraine that's quite a
transition there huh or yet Biden and
the radical Democrats do nothing to stop
the death and Devastation that we have
happening right here at home
they've deliberately surrendered our
border to vicious coyotes and Drug
smaller I mean these drug smoke
a Smuggler is a vicious third glitch of
the night oftentimes very smart person
and what we do is we set up Blue Ribbon
committees
composed of some nice dilettants
you know nice gentle people
tell us about what to do about the
coyotes and the cartels and all of this
and now you have to do something very
strong it's it's called the death
penalty and you're gonna you're gonna
have no drug problem you're gonna have
crime will go down to a level
to a level that you haven't seen but you
know I see the Blue Ribbon committees
because I get many calls so I'd love to
serve on the committee on coyotes on
cartels
and these are not people that can do
that job but they're very fine people in
some cases and some people some people
just want the publicity but we have to
get very tough on that and if you don't
do the death penalty you know I was with
it is quite difficult to follow what
this guy is talking about stuff you
could go all over Hollywood if you
wanted to play the role of presidency he
just got I guess he just got elected for
life right somebody said his president
she's smart I said yeah he actually is
very smart brilliant and the fake news
back there is a lot of them the fake
news
the fake news said president Trump said
the president of China president for
life of China
it's like oh I'm the king he's the king
of China right 1.5 billion people he
said he was smart he might have even
said he was brilliant how dare he say
that oh okay he's in charge of 1.5
billion people they want me to say no
he's not a smart person it was just luck
but I said to him let me ask you do you
have a drug problem in China
and he looked at me like what the hell
stupid question is that of course would
uh he actually did he said no he goes no
no no no no no what's wrong why do you
ask such a stupid question
but I said no you don't you have 1.5
billion people you have no drug problem
the only problem they have is they make
the drugs and send them here which they
were stopping with me I said don't do
that you can't do the fentanyl they make
the Fentanyl and send it through our
horribly run
Southern border but I said so you don't
have right you don't have why quick
trial
what's a quick try I thought I knew what
a quick trial was but I said what is it
when we catch a drug dealer we give them
a trial quickly
and if they're guilty they get executed
and they send the bullet Bullet to the
family
and they want the family to pay for the
cost of the bullet this is called not
playing around so not sounding super
constitutional get the hell out of here
they don't do it there and they don't do
it in Singapore and other countries too
Singapore and if you want to stop the
drug epidemic in this country you better
do that and it's a hard thing to mention
it's a hard thing to talk about and does
Trump's extremely spiritual and as a
result he's pro-life you can tell many
of the fake news they say oh that's
terrible that he's talking about that
each drug dealer over a period of their
life his or her life will kill 500
people Americans mostly 500 think of it
so I've tried to fact check that so many
times and I found no evidence at all for
it to play nice but you can't play nice
he's a smart vicious tough people the
cartels they own now Mexico I mean
they're running Mexico and the president
is a very good friend of mine but it's a
very tough thing happened it's the most
unsafe country anywhere in the world
Mexico rated number one most unsafe
worse than Afghanistan you believe it
because of the drugs and the drugs are
all most of it are pouring right into
our country so we better get smart and
if we do something that I think most of
the people in this audience want we're
going to get that done we're going to
get that done you have no choice
you know much of our crime Dan Trump's
lying about everything I mean just what
he said the least safe country is
Afghanistan followed by Yemen Syria
Russia South Sudan Congo Iraq Somalia
Central African Republic Mexico is not
even on the top ten list 85 80 of the
crime coming into our country so we
better get smart and tough and
start using a little common sense right
not conservative Common Sense somebody
said are you a conservative I said well
I am but I'm a person with a lot of
common sense that's why we had such a
successful country two years ago energy
independent
no inflation little things like that
since the end of the Trump
Administration the drug cartels have
seen their revenues Skyrocket by an
astounding two thousand five hundred
percent if there were if that's true
it's because of covid easing 500 million
dollars to last year 13
dollars in one year this is what they're
making the choice this November is
simple Democrats will defund the police
Republicans will defund the cartels
under my leadership
we waged a very tough war on the cartels
we ended Catch and Release we stopped
Asylum fraud we deported illegal alien
gang members by the thousands and
thousands we sent them back got them the
hell out of our country
and the other countries didn't want to
take them back but we were giving them a
lot of money I said how much money do we
give El Salvador and Honduras and these
various countries they said sir
approximately 750 million dollars a year
I said that's a lot
so I said what's the problem they said
they won't take them back they won't
take MSP defects or they will not do it
they're not going to take them back sir
they've told us no they wouldn't do it
under the
Barack Hussein Obama administration they
wouldn't do it
they wouldn't do
it so I said that's what I said how much
do we pay them you know what they do
when we fly in with a plane they put
planes on the runway so that we couldn't
land when the buses came in they'd stop
them at the border send them back to
they didn't want their MS-13 people back
even though they came from various
places so I said here's what you do we
give them 750 million dollars a year
tomorrow put out a statement or today I
think I said today like this afternoon
put out a statement that we're not
paying them anymore
we're not paying them anymore
and we did and the following morning I
got a call from the three primary
countries
and Guatemala Honduras El Salvador
the president uh we understand you're
unhappy Max silicone you know you won't
take MS-13 back Uncle Sam look at Uncle
Sam stand up Uncle Sam he's the greatest
they're trying to cancel Uncle Sam you
know that right Uncle Sam is no longer
politically correct you're always going
to be politically correct no they want
to cancel
but they said President we understand
you're unhappy I said yeah you won't
take back the people that you send
because they send them they don't just
come they send them they make it easy
for them they send them they'll be
stupid they keep their good people they
fight like hell that the good people
don't leave the bad people they say send
them to the stupid people at the United
States
and you see what they're doing what
they're building for them they're living
better than our soldiers they're living
better than our veterans they're living
better than the people in our country
they're building things that are
beautiful
but they said we hear you happy I said
look here's the story you're not getting
any more money you're not getting
anything what you're doing to us and
then you don't let us send them back we
the people of ice the people of ice are
incredible the border patrol is
incredible all of the law enforcements I
said you won't take them back most of
what Trump says the crowd doesn't
understand and in their defense I don't
understand it either so whenever he hits
buzzwords like um border patrol they're
like oh now we can clap that sounds good
president may we call you back in 10
minutes absolutely calls me back anyway
president we've decided that it would be
an honor to take MS-13 back to our
country it'll be a great great honor we
will take them back sir and we will do
it please I mean they build new airports
if we needed it so this is what happens
we have people that just don't know what
the hell they're doing it's uh so sad to
watch what's happening to our country
our country has never been so low it's a
laughing stock all over the world we
built hundreds of miles of border wall
and despite two and a half years of
democrat lawsuits they tried to stop it
I won all of the lawsuit we finished the
first phase of the wall then I said
let's add some more we added 200 miles
more and we would have had more than
that and this story of what happened
with the wall is a complete and total
lie it's about not wanting to close up
the Border because they refused in fact
Texas wanted to finish up the wall and
they wouldn't let him use the wall that
was already built and sitting there
ready to be installed in three weeks the
additional wall that I didn't even say
we were going to do but we needed it was
going to be built the wall is why we had
the best numbers in the history we had
very few people relatively coming in and
we really stopped human trafficking to a
large extent that we stopped drugs
did you guys know that human trafficking
was over under Trump by two Rock Solid
Defenders of America Sovereign borders
and this guy is an amazing guy he's a
friend of mine and the people that work
with him at the top and everybody in
there is just incredible president of
the national border patrol Council Mr
Brandon Judd he's fantastic where's
Brandon come here
they're so important and you know
they're Heroes and they get treated very
badly but I get treated worse than
anybody in history so
I got like 400 investigations friend of
mine said you are the most honest person
in history why he said you've been under
investigation for five six seven years
they got nothing okay they got
they looked at 11 million pages of
documents they got nothing these people
they're a bunch of bad people they've
weaponized they've weaponized this stuff
it's terrible but Brandon Judd has done
an incredible job and uh another person
that I mean this guy is Brenda this guy
is Central Casting Tom Holman acting
director of ice there was nobody better
tougher or smarter when it came to the
border and all they had to do all Biden
had to do is just say all he had to do
is go to the beach he could have stayed
in Delaware even he could have stayed in
his basement like he did all he had to
do was go to the beach what does that
mean because the Border was in great
shape and only getting better and Tom
Holman come up wherever you are Tom
Hallman and Brandon say a couple of
words please
you gotta love the bismind you have to
love that nobody in the history brought
a business mind to the White House he
cut through the bureaucracy he cut
through all of the BS the red tape he
implemented policies immediately it was
funny when you ask any of them what
exactly what red tape did he cut nobody
has any answers
save your lives your children's lives
your grandchildren's lives your friends
lives your neighbors lives that's what
he did and that's what we hope you're
gonna do again thank you
extremely fascistic
praise
well look I think I told you earlier
during my speech I was pretty clear
president Trump was one badass president
really what did he do he was bad I don't
know about bad ass I joined a board
during 1984 I've enforced immigration
law for over 34 years I worked for six
different presidents no president did
more to secure our board and president
Trump
bottom line
and I'll share with you what I told the
president a few weeks ago in Las Vegas
he comes back I come back
and and you are who again and why do we
want you back that's a good deal
tell you one thing the problem will end
on day one so Tom and Brandon we thank
you and we salute every Hero Of Ice And
border patrol and law enforcement
generally I took a lot of pictures
back there with your sheriffs and we had
some incredible conversations the law
enforcement of this country is quick we
have to let them do their job they will
straighten it out they're incredible
people we have to protect them too we
have to help them thanks to the open
borders policies of the radical
Democrats every day Texas Community
suffer the spilling of innocent blood
and the killing of innocent life like
you've never seen before it's never
happened anywhere near what's happening
now the numbers are higher than they've
ever been by far just a few days ago an
illegal alien in McGregor Texas was
charged with the savagely murdering a 38
year old woman and her two teenage
children beautiful children and then
continuing his deadly Rampage in the
house next door that he went to another
one and another one before he was caught
he was massacring helpless people
including a 47 year old woman and her
precious 20 year old daughter
who was studying to become a doctor
doing really well top of her class
before driving down the street wildly
firing gunshots wounding yet another
innocent victim was finally caught
and let's see what happens let's see
what happens because they catch him now
and then they release him the Democrats
in El Paso this month three illegal
aliens were arrested for the brutal
murder of a 28 year old man after
shooting him multiple times and dumping
his body on the side of the road
and last year in Harris County two
illegal alien MS-13 animals were
convicted of kidnapping three teenage
girls raping them and sadistically
murdering the 15 year old girl in a
trump does this at every speech now he
does these lurid stories with no real
connection to actual Biden policy of any
kind of force the restoration of every
single Trump border security we have
Trump or another glitch
I've never seen him this glitchy every
one of those measures every one of those
beautiful powerful and very fair
measures that achieve the strongest
Border in history we want them put back
in place instead of doubling the number
of IRS agents who are allowed to carry
guns okay so we have 87 88 000. remember
um 87 000 55 000 is to replace retiring
agents
and of those I forget it there's like a
few hundred who carry firearms it's it's
it's just such a lie maybe it was a
thousand total that carry firearms
double the number of ice and border
patrol agents double them quickly right
and we should pass emergency funding to
give our Texas border communities the
security resources and help they sow
dearly deserve you know the Border
the border is an amazing thing I got a
call from the governor on
election evening late and he said you
know you did something that we never
thought was possible
so what's that he said you won every
Border Town every single Border Town
with the Hispanics you won every single
one
and
he said that hasn't happened since the
Civil War can you believe that
he said that hasn't happened it's such
an honor we started this whole thing and
now it's really really picking up steam
in Florida they gave me the Bay of Pigs
award that was a big deal actually the
Bay of Pigs they didn't give it to a
Democrat they gave it is that another
one of those fake Awards like the
Michigan Man Of The Year the major
reasons why Hispanic Americans are
joining our Movement by the millions and
millions and millions
in 2020 I was honored to earn the
highest percentage of Latino votes of
any Republican in debts really decades
decades I think right Ronnie
and I became the first Republican to win
Zapata County in a hundred years Zapata
100 years
but it's true that's a great honor these
are great people these are hard-working
people and you know what they want they
want security
very entrepreneurial people they really
they really are
they becoming a real part of the
Republican party it's incredible this
all happened over the last few years the
Republican party is now the proud home
of a new generation of Hispanic leaders
like Cassie Garcia where is she Cassie
Garcia
Monica De La Cruz
oh this could get risky
a real star Myra Flores
who recently became the first Republican
ever to win her congressional district
On the Border first ever
she's fantastic
smart all of them to every Hispanic
American in Texas Arizona and all across
our land we welcome you to our party and
to our movement with open open beautiful
strong arms so I want to thank you all
throw them because together we will make
America great and glorious again
among our first or most
crucial tasks is to make America safe
again we can't have a great country if
we're not safe if people walk down the
street and they get slugged from behind
by some Maniac under the radical left
Democrats the streets of our cities are
ruled by bloodthirsty gangs and violent
criminals like never before nobody's
ever seen anything like this Austin set
an all-time record for homicides last
year an all-time record not even close
by the way and the number of Hispanic
murder victims nationwise it wise is up
40 percent plus they think it's at least
40 percent
with the Republican Congress we must
also pass critical funding to hire
thousands more police officers
Nationwide to put violent criminals
Behind Bars and keep them behind bars
for a long time
we have to protect our police death
penalty if you kill a police person
death penalty
we need to leave our police alone and
let them do their job if you want safety
for your family and security for your
community you need to know every
Democrat out of you have to get them out
you have to you have to know that every
Democrat is against the things that the
people here tonight and this is an
incredible crowd the people here tonight
all right who do you think's the worst
person Trump or Kanye at this point
[Applause]
two days notice can you it's happening
like this all over the country by the
way in all fairness all we were in
Michigan Arizona we were all over all
over the country Nevada
we have massive crowds everyone we're we
give them like two days notice that we
have thousands and thousands of people
show up
but we want you to vote straight
Republican one of the worst most
Sinister aspects of the Biden
Administration is the complete and total
Corruption of our justice system and the
rule of law before our very eyes Biden
and his left-wing handlers are turning
America into a police state and I don't
even think it's Biden to be honest with
you but they got some bad people around
a police state like something straight
out of a communist country see I used to
say socialists but we've skipped
socialism we don't talk about that it's
a police state in which they've removed
all the law enforcement from the border
to make it completely Lawless about
Communists is a communist system that
we're putting up with right now the
radical Democrats are locking up
pro-life activists persecuting their
political opponents spying on their
political Rivals
silencing dissent and using the full
force of government law enforcement and
the media to try and Crush our movement
and let me tell you the media is a big
problem because they're corrupt and
dishonest
foreign
as an example all you have to do is look
this week the FBI paid two hundred
thousand dollars to one of its
informants to help them obtain bogus
Pfizer warrants against me and peddle
the fake Russia hoax remember that the
little thing called you notice nobody
talks about it and yet they gave out the
Pulitzer Prize for reporting on the
Russia hoax okay reporting on Russia
Russia Russia
so you have reporters from The
Washington Post the New York Times
they've got Pulitzer prizes and they
reported the exact wrong thing so within
the next two weeks we're suing the
Pulitzer organization to have those
prizes taken back yeah
I'm sure that'll be a really successful
lawsuit like all the others we'll be
doing that over the next two weeks I
think it's a very good lawsuit but we'll
see but uh we'll put we're soon think of
it they got the Pulitzer Prize for wrong
reporting
but other people
should have gotten the Pulitzer Prize
because frankly they got it right for
years
and they don't do Pulitzer prizes for
guys like Sean Hannity
by a different name and Tucker Carlson
and Janine Pirro oh that's rich
and Laura imagine Janine Pirro getting a
Pulitzer that's now that's rich full of
surprises to the people that got her
wrong remember this by allowing these
people that got Russia Russia Russia
wrong they're actually labeling me
because they're saying they got it right
and it turned out to be a hoax and
everybody now has admitted it was a hoax
even the times and even the Washington
Post they said it's a hoax so if it's a
hoax then let them give the Pulitzer
prizes back or take them back they
shouldn't be allowed to keep them
thank you
the FBI even offered you saw this one
last week one million dollars found out
by
John Durham to the author of the fake
dossier how about that fake dossier you
think it was great when I had to go home
that night not so good
I'm sure you don't know what I'm talking
about that was not the greatest oh now
as you guys know Durham has been an
embarrassment uh multiple acquittals now
in what was supposed to be the trial of
the century for the political crime of
the century Obama gate Durham has
nothing it's been three years of Durham
there's nothing there believe because he
said germ freak
I don't believe that
but they offered one million dollars to
the author of the fake dossier
Christopher Steele a real low life to
corroborate his false story they wanted
it corroborated they will give you think
of that they'll give him a million
dollars if he will say
that we corroborate these facts are true
but he couldn't do it because they were
unto and it was all against me this is
what I've been fighting can you believe
this what the hell kind of a life I used
to have such a nice life what the hell
did I do I got these Maniacs that are
looking to destroy our country
right doc Ronnie they're looking to
destroy our country we're like they're
not stupid people well some are actually
but they're not stupid people
so they can only I mean either they're
stupid or they're looking to destroy
because who wants this stuff to happen
who wants this to happen who wants to
have open borders who wants to have no
voter ID who wants to have they don't
want anybody talking about whether or
not you're a citizen when they go into
vote no citizenship verification you
can't even register to vote unless
you're a citizen even Democrats want it
if you poll it not even Democrats want
it it's a it's a shame so I don't
believe they're stupid so therefore
they're trying to destroy our country
because it could only be one of those
two things every freedom loving American
needs to understand the time to stand up
to this growing tyranny is right now
it's right now we got to do it let's do
it
foreign
[Music]
like the January 6th Committee of
unselect
unselect political thugs
you know you know January is the
unselects I never got any credit I think
that was one of the great names
unselects they're unselect
it's supposed to be you know there's a
the Select Committee of political you
know
by the way how did Liz Cheney do it she
lost by 40 points
and then the corrupt press they say Liz
Cheney We Believe has a great future in
politics she lost by 40 points the
single biggest margin a congressman or
woman has ever lost by a history and
then they say we feel she has a fine
future in politics I don't think so
but January so all she does is Judge
would say she's like obsessed so here
and uh he's like totally obsessed guys
she cries
these are the people we had but remember
this January 6 this committee
the two things they didn't talk about
two things was that the people went down
there and you could have had over a
million people
[Applause]
wow it's a call
oh my God
[Applause]
I'm sorry guys I wasn't planning on a
cringe stream today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how do these people even hold a job you
know
[Applause]
hold on I'm coming
further screamed that his days are
numbered
all right
[Music]
dead
wow that's so beautiful you know when
this whole big group stood up I said oh
we have protesters
they are protesting they are protesting
what's taking place in our country and
it's so bad and so wrong it is a protest
oh my God
so the unselect committee
a political like a mix of Castro and
Putin it's the same people that did
Russia Russia Russia you know
Shifty shift
Shifty atom shift what what a sleazeback
he is
and all these people the same people
that did the Russia hoax and then when
they realized it's a hoax they realize
they do from the beginning they made it
up it was all made up but when they get
caught a couple of days go by then they
start the Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine they
start the Mueller deal they said these
are the same people these people are
sick they should spend time on trying to
make our country great not this crap
all they do is investigate we're like a
nation that's all we do is investigate
and frankly it's interesting how bodies
charged with investigating investigate
like the FBI they keep investigating
stuff the house they keep investigating
stuff their country
but remember this and I'm going to get
off this subject but please January 6
January 6
January 6 was caused because of a
crooked stolen election and they don't
even talk about it during the January
6th he's justifying it never even
discussed he's justifying it
so they don't discuss that and what's
the second thing they don't discuss
Nancy Pelosi is in charge of security in
the capital Ronnie knows this better
than anybody there remember that that is
untrue Trump claims he asked for 10 000
soldiers there is no evidence of that
request I'm gonna discuss that
I authorize from ten to twenty thousand
lives should they need them four days
three days earlier there is no evidence
of that he's changing the number he used
to say ten thousand now he says ten to
twenty thousand it is a lie there is no
evidence of that there's no record that
he did that maybe over a million people
that said you ever see a picture that
that and other great Patriots spoke
before they never talk about that and
they never talk about the fact that
Nancy Pelosi refused to use the military
and they didn't need ten thousand to
twenty thousand if they had 500 people
who would have this is all completely
untrue this is truly horrific it's it
lies on top of Lies they never talk
about and they sent me a subpoena the
other the day zavina they sent me a
Cepeda think of it
these crooked people
these crooked people and the only thing
they don't invest they don't want to do
investigate that's another glitch and
Trump is completely losing it it was the
corruption that took place in that
election which was massive and the facts
are all there we have some really
unhinged hinge so you can say you take a
look at most of the people in this
audience know it because you know a lot
more and these people back there they
don't want to cover it and that's the
problem that we have with our country
right now because the fake news will not
even there's only right-wing media at
the back of that room if you're an
anchor like Lou Dobbs who's great if
you're an anchor and you know it's right
and you talk about it you lose your job
you get fired it's a disgrace oh my God
if you want to save your rights and
Liberties you have to start by dealing a
crushing rebuke to the radical left
Maniacs that we're dealing with in this
election these are Maniacs this is for
six straight years the witch hunts
hoaxes abuses have been coming Fast and
Furious mostly aimed at me isn't that
nice What a Wonderful Life
our great first lady said what a
wonderful job this is so lovely every
day you get a subpoena
if I fly over a Democrat state in my
little play that we flew over you did
you see that
right my man
if we fly over a Democrat State back in
five I get it grand jury subpoena
I said what happened what'd you do sir
they're investigating you you flew over
the state they think something's up
they've been looking at me for a long
time Dr Ronnie I'll tell you what they
found nothing they have found
one thing I will say they found that I
like you am a great Patriot that's what
they found
it's a disgrace what's going on
like the boxes hoax have you looked at
the boxes hoax okay this is a new one
the boxes you know Mar-A-Lago have you
seen the last five or six presidents
what they did they took it they're in
Chinese laundries they're stored they're
in storage houses where the windows and
doors are broken it's a disgrace but if
you names Trump
you have to take a look at it read Greg
Jarrett's piece it's a disgrace what's
going on in our country so first we
learned they spired my campaign could
you imagine if we spied on let's say
Obama's campaign okay let's say we spied
they would reinstitute the death penalty
with me it's uh well I don't know with
us they call it a conspiracy theory no
they spotted our campaign and we caught
them remember a long time ago I put out
you know they spied on my campaign and
everyone said what a horrible thing to
say if that ever happened to Obama or a
Democrat forget about Biden don't even
talk about Biden any Democrat
if that ever happened it would be the
biggest story in history think of it
they spied on a president's campaign
including for a period of time when he
was in the white house that's the
biggest story of our time and these
crooked reporters don't want to even
talk about it
then they lied to Congress many times
you know Comey and all those guys they
lied to Congress you know that many
times
and then they lied to the Pfizer Court
many many times and they created a fake
dossier that was done and paid for by
crooked Hillary Clinton the Democrats
Democratic National Committee
it was well paid for by the Democrat
Party the Democrat National Committee
and crooked Hillary and yet after all of
that these same people
they come after me
they spotted my campaign to come after
me
and we have attorney generals that
didn't have the courage to do what they
had to do because he didn't want to be
impeached please don't impeach me
you know how he doesn't get impeached to
say oh I think the election was perfect
it was so wonderful check out Detroit
check out Philadelphia check out Atlanta
to disgrace no it's a disgrace that's
why when I hear about Ken Paxton and I
see Ken Paxton Ken Paxton shouldn't even
have a race he's done such a great job
he shouldn't even have a race
stand up Ken where the hell are you kid
he shouldn't even have a race I would
have been proud to have him in the white
house he wouldn't have done that
how do you not get impeached they wanted
to impeach our attorney general how do
you not get impeached all you do is say
oh the election was wonderful then they
say we're not impeaching this guy man we
just hit Pay Dirt remember it was Russia
Russia Russia Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine
and then the Mueller Witch Hunt
where the conclusion was no collusion
you think Biden could say that I don't
think so the conclusion
think of that the conclusion was no
collusion
that would be a tough one if they wrote
that for Biden that would be the end of
their job
he'd still be trying to figure it out
and then they had impeachment hoax
number one impeachment hoax number two
the censorship of the Biden family
corruption story as Russian
disinformation by the FBI and Facebook
so the FBI goes up
to Facebook and to other media people
back there and says
that the laptop from hell was Russian
disinformation even though no they knew
it was untrue
this is what we're dealing with and
nothing's going to happen to them
nothing happens to them it's a disgrace
our country is very sick
and that made a 17-point difference they
say according to John McLaughlin and
Tony Fabrizio and a lot of the great
pollsters had made from 10 to 17 points
but it made a tremendous difference
didn't matter we got more votes that we
needed anyway they just cheated they
would have figured a way to cheat that
too that's what we have to be careful
with this selection that they're not
allowed to cheat they cannot be allowed
to cheat again and then it was the
unselect committee of political hacks
and Thugs and also appalling misconduct
by the racist and incompetent New York
state attorney generals he's incompetent
Leticia peekaboo James
who is presiding over record numbers of
murders rapes drug deals and every other
form of crime in our once great New York
State
but only spends her time going after me
let's go after Trump I have we have this
woman peekaboo James she goes that she
runs on getting Trump I'm gonna get him
I'm gonna get him she doesn't know
anything about me she just sees my name
I'm gonna get him
years and years and yet you have people
being murdered in the street
and there was no crime I did nothing
wrong but yet people murdered on the
street you have drug dealers all over
and she couldn't care less she's the
worst so we'll see what happens there
with her election I hear she's losing
wouldn't that be amazing if Sheila
and I hear lee zeldin is winning because
you know what the people of New York
just like the people in Texas and
everywhere else you're tired of crime
you don't want crime you want to have
low taxes you want to have great
education you want to have a strong
military you want to have all the things
that people with
comment you know what you want you want
voter ID you know what you really want
you want paper ballots and same day
voting with voter rifle
otherwise you'll never get it straight
if you don't do that France just had an
election 36 million people it's a big
nation 36 million people voted by paper
they voted same day
and they have voter ID
and by 11 o'clock in the evening there
was a winner there was a loser everyone
went home and they said let's get them
next time but if you don't go to paper
ballots and if you don't go to voter ID
and if you don't go to same-day voting
these things that take place for over 48
days
sir we have boxes stored at a storage
remote where are they oh well they
haven't been we haven't seen them for a
while Mike have any of those boxes where
are they right now they seem to have
disappeared but what's going on with
them tonight he's just like even
stranger than usual see anything so
crazy
we have a corrupt country we have a
horrible and we have really sick
elections and nobody one thing you
learned a lot from me you've learned
about those things borders and elections
and I can't tell you which is worse and
I can't actually tell you which is more
important I think elections might even
be more important than the Border
because if you get the right people
you'll solve the Border problem
the radical left things by doing all
these Wicked and venomous things they
are making us weaker but actually they
are making us stronger and more united
than ever before
they're coming after me because I'm
fighting for you and that is true
[Applause]
thank you darling thank you I'm glad you
weren't protesters it's a nice group
that was very well done
I didn't know what the hell happened
this group what a great group of people
where are you from where
that's beautiful that's beautiful thank
you thank you
[Applause]
this I mean it's it's a cult it's a cult
there's no way around it these are cult
members and as you know cult beliefs can
be very stubborn very very stubborn
we've interviewed cult experts
but we have to save our country it's
nice to say we love Trump we have to
save our country by the way I'm speaking
to this group here they stood up it was
so beautiful actually it was actually a
beautiful moment
they're too smart to say bad things it's
too dangerous in this group to say bad
things you notice we don't have much of
that I haven't had that in two years
they used at the beginning they stand up
we're not like you the poor guys thought
it was terrible then I always got blamed
remember but we haven't had that but you
know this country
is really United We The Reason Trump was
blamed is he would offer to pay people
beating the crap out of protesters legal
fees and the country was really United
and I'm talking left and right
when we turned it around prior to covet
we had every single group doing better
than it had ever done in history the
country had done better than it ever
done in history
and people from the radical left were
calling me to get together I said you
know
because as some people say to me and I
say to them it would be great if we
could unite everyone the right and the
left and everybody and I never knew that
it was going to be possible but prior to
our horrible horrible gift that came out
of the Wuhan Labs of China
prior to China and the dust shine that
they sent over what a disgrace and we're
gonna someday that's gonna we're gonna
do something China because what happened
what they've done to the world forget
about 60 trillion dollars in damage they
cannot afford that by the way just so
you know
but prior to that coming in our country
African-Americans Hispanic Americans
Asian Americans women men kids with a
high school diploma kids without a high
school diploma first in your class at
the Wharton School of Finance MIT
Harvard
people that didn't get a college diploma
Namaste every single group without even
one nobody everybody has was doing
better than ever before by a lot and I
was getting calls from the radical left
can we get together and then that
horrible thing happened the China virus
I call it because I want to be accurate
not covid-19 covet 19. where does that
come from covid donate plasma from the
China virus came in and then we had to
redo it again and we did an incredible
job with operation supposing we hit the
body with a tremendous uh very powerful
light apply light and heat to cure and
then I see the disinfectant is there a
way we can do something like that
by injection inside supposing you
brought the light inside the body can't
let this stuff happen to our country
we're not going to have a country and
when that result took it and they took
over
think of it and remember he was going to
sell oh we're going to have the vaccine
out we're going to have all this stuff
done it can take only if I mean more
people died in that first year of him
than under us and it was getting much
better but think of it with all of the
things that happened everything that
happened what's he trying the stock
market it was getting much worse it was
higher when I handed it over than it was
before just prior to the China virus
coming in to our country think of that
we gave an unbelievable country back and
now our country is being destroyed
energy is a disaster
crime is a disaster the border is a
disaster our military is going woke our
military is
getting to be an embarrassment and great
people are leaving our military and
great people are leaving our law
enforcement too
to every citizen who is appalled by the
radical left's lawlessness and
Corruption this election is your chance
to make your voice heard you have to do
it you have to do it with your vote you
can reject left-wing tyranny and proudly
declare that America will always remain
a free country got to be a free country
tell you what
we're really on the borderline I used to
say during the 2016 election well we
didn't do as well as the other ones
frankly but I used to say that if we
don't get this right we're going to be
Venezuela on steroids and that's where
we're going we're right now going to be
soon Venezuela on steroids you can take
the five worst Presidents in American
history and put them together and they
would not have done the damage Joe Biden
has done to our nation in less than two
years
Let's Take a Look by the way we have a
little video take a look at this oh no
how would you say your mental focus is
focused
I said I think it's I I haven't look
Ed
oh my God I think it's a right for
people to have bad account care
true International pressure guys
said that America is a nation that can
be defined in this meanwhile I've had
more investigations than Jesse James and
Billy the cut we've endorsed JP right JD
Mandel Kofi no more
hide then he went Donald Trump killed
Donald Trump if you care about law and
auto take a look at the oranges of the
investigation advising lawmakers you
know Mike did me on 60 Minutes and the
combat infant tripping truth essential
yeah
come on man
my my uh the guy who runs that outfit
over there
I've had a couple I should
[Applause]
but the nature
not
representative Jackie are you here
where's Jackie I think she was going to
be here
um
what am I doing here I'm Tucker
yeah
I got hairy legs that turn that that
that that thank you for tolerance for
listening to me I appreciate very much
what
and then
quite an electric atmosphere at this
rally
all right
thank you
now that's a very sad thing you know I I
looked
I went through a list of the leaders
most of whom I know and some I know very
well in any country you want to talk
about those leaders are at the top of
their game
they are at the top of their game
they're sharp they're smart they're
tough and they're for their country it's
their country first and with us it has
to be our country first but we have to
have people that know what they're doing
they don't believe what's going on I
think they're really ones that have
respected us over the year
over the years
the ones that really think like
America's smart I'll tell you what they
respected us two years ago they
respected us like they never respected
us there was no games Ukraine would have
never happened inflation would have
never happened Energy prices would have
never happened like they are
but they respected our nation all of
these things that we're looking at were
self-made they were unnecessary to
happen
and what's going on now is so sad but
the other leaders they think that we're
playing because they respected us for so
many years but especially in the last
four or five years prior to This
Disaster happening and they think we're
playing four-dimensional chess does that
make sense no you say there's no way
this is happening that country is too
smart it's four dimensional presidency
probably has a meeting and he says wait
a minute this can't be possible
they're too smart for that it's
four-dimensional Justice does anyone
know what that means I know what that
means they you know what it means they
can't believe what the hell is going on
with our country under my leadership we
had for the first time American and
didn't say our kante very low prices
and even energy dominance we're going to
dominate the entire world on energy we
were bigger
than Russia and Saudi Arabia combined
within a very short period of time we're
going to be dominant now Biden is
begging and pleading with OPEC but
instead of increasing production they're
cutting it off think of it
oil has reached an all-time high let's
not go for oil anymore
and we have more than anybody
we gave you the largest tax cuts and
regulation Cuts in American history by
contrast the radical democrat congress
passed one of the largest tax hikes in
American history it was the largest tax
hike I believe in American history under
the Trump Administration we had the
greatest economy in the history of the
world with no inflation Biden and the
democrat congress created the worst
inflation in 50 years
9.1 percent but it's much higher than
that
you see your bills it's much higher
I rebuilt our military including our
nuclear capability which hopefully we'll
never have to use
and the creation of space force first
time since Air Force 79 years
79 years ago we did Air Force this was
space force new branch and it's turning
out to be very very powerful and
important they surrendered our strength
and turned Afghanistan into the greatest
humiliation our country has ever had
and now we have a war between Russia and
Ukraine with potentially hundreds of
thousands of people dying that would
never ever ever in a million years have
happened if I were president and in
addition to that the oil prices would
have been low enough that they wouldn't
have been able to afford the war but we
didn't even need that he would have
Putin would have never done it I know
him well
the election was rigged and stolen and
now our country is being destroyed I ran
twice I won twice and did much better
the second time than I did the first
getting Millions more votes in 2020 than
we got in 2016.
and likewise getting more votes than any
sitting president in the history of our
country by far but what about buying now
in order to make our country successful
safe and glorious again
I will probably have to do it again uh
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
right this guy should be in prison and
we will bend men
oh
yeah
thank you very much
but first we have to win a historic
victory for the Republican party this
November
right here in Texas you have the
opportunity to defeat a man who is
against God Guns and oil that's pretty
bad Texas we're talking about God's gun
guns and oil Beto O'Rourke Beto
vote he will abolish oil
abolish our borders and abolish your
second amendment that's what it is
remember when he got up and he was
pandering to the Democrats and he said
he's going to get rid of your guns
in contrast you have a wonderful man
he's a wonderful man
you're Governor Greg Abbott he's strong
on borders
he supports our police
and he's turned Texas into a gigantic
jobs Magda it's done a great job
so I want you to get out and vote for
Greg Abbott he's a very very good person
a very special man in addition Texas
needs to re-elect your outstanding
friend of mine Lieutenant Governor Dan
Patrick Dan
come on up there oh no Dan was in charge
of my campaign in Texas and we won big
Dan has been a tireless Champion for
border security and he will do whatever
it takes
to stop this Invasion Dan Patrick is one
of the weirdest guys in politics assault
on Texas but it's an assault on the
United States Dan backs the blue 100
percent he personally worked to ensure
that every Texas law enforcement officer
is a bulletproof vest
he wants to crack down on far left
district attorneys that he strongly
resisted covet lockdowns and mandates to
keep Texas free and when your state
faced an energy crisis caused by the
radical left he showed true leadership
demanding the resignation of the entire
Public Utility Commission so I will tell
you he's an incredible guy a wonderful
man he headed up my campaign twice in
Texas how did we do Dan we won
way one big by one of the smallest
margins for a republican in 40 years two
down so Dan please say a few words
Dan Patrick just exudes alpha male
masculinity and energy
after Hurricane Harvey
within days you were not far away here
in Corpus Christi
and whether it was
Harvey relief
building a strong oil and gas industry
making crime numbers go down securing
the Border giving us the strongest
economy that we have had in decades you
made the life of every one of 29 million
Texans better
and Joe Biden has made the life of every
Texan worse
and we do about 42 percent of Texans
disagree in Texas
Mr President this is your home
we love you
thank you what you've done for Texas and
America
he's like every single Texan it's like a
little more than half come on guys
good job Dan
that's great great guy great man
Dan is running against by the way a
Biden loving radical Democrat named Mike
Collier who is vowed to push Texas far
far far to the left not what you want
for this state Mike Collier will fight
for open borders Sanctuary cities Joe
Biden and Nancy Pelosi's gun control
agenda
and green New Deal inspired energy
policies which will close up everything
in Texas it's going to be a disaster
so Texas does not need a Biden Pelosi
stooge lieutenant governor
you need a great person it's a very
important I don't know if you know in
Texas the position of lieutenant
governor is a very powerful position a
lot of a lot of power a lot of things
happen a lot of things are under the
control of the lieutenant governor and
Dan Patrick has been absolutely
incredible strong powerful with a big
beautiful heart and he's my friend thank
you very much Dan
great job
thank you thank you Dan
this election day you also need to get
out and vote for your incredible
attorney general I'm sorry but I have to
thank user Donald Trump for 21-month
subscribed president Donald J Trump they
know it already Ken Ken they know it
and you know what being controversial is
okay
it's okay
one of the reasons he's controversial
because he does things
no State Attorney General in America is
tougher or stronger than Ken in terms of
what he does for crime and against Crime
and he's a legal Powerhouse he really is
every day Ken gets up
and holds Joe Biden's feet to the fire
he doesn't know as well as anybody there
is in the country he doesn't do an
Administration over the
horrible open border policies and Asylum
rules that they instituted all they had
to do is leave
Tom holmen's ideas alone Tom Holman is
Tom Holmen by the way Central Casting
he's Central Casting he stood up to
Biden's illegal targeting of parents at
school board meetings
he's taking on big Pharma like nobody
else and it's his radicals to stop the
use of puberty blockers to multitude of
a multitude of minor children yeah
they're giving puberty blockers to
five-year-olds who are nowhere near
going through puberty wait a second what
does that make I don't know at parental
rights now today it's a big subject
politically it's ridiculous
and earlier this year Ken scored a
gigantic victory over the Biden
Administration blocking their extreme
environmental policies including their
destructive moratorium on oil and gas
leasing on public lands remember I used
to tell you he's not telling the truth
whenever he needed to say a debate she'd
say oh no no I'm well for oily guest but
it turned out to be false we got him on
the last question of the second debate I
said oh wait if I felt like Perry Mason
I said wait a minute he just said it
he's not but nobody listened although
actually you did we got a lot of votes
didn't we yeah Trump felt like Perry
Mason over something that he misheard
and then was confused about integrity
you know that and he's running against
an ultra leftist named Rochelle Garza
real real beauty that one Gars is an
open borders fanatic who slandered the
heroes of border patrol calling them
Shameless and cowardly I don't think we
can allow that to happen
we can't allow that to happen
she opposes the border wall she opposes
my remain in Mexico how about that I got
a policy I got to get that done with
Mexico the great president of Mexico
he's a wonderful guy he's a socialist
but can't have everything right but I
got along with him great but we got it
done
and we did a lot of things done with
Mexico
we got 28 000 free soldiers remember
that oh not this story you know how we
got him right oh no no I said listen no
you have 28 000 I need 28 000 which is
what we're building the wall and the
people at Mexico the representative said
no no no we're not Max silicone and I
met somebody in the state department a
very good woman but she's been dealing
with Mexico for 25 years she said sir
you can't get that they'll never do it
I've been asking for many years I said
really let's see what happens
then I gave her 10 other things that we
should get because I went to the border
patrol and you two guys gave me the
things that you Most Wanted 10 things
and they ended up making it 12. I said
I'll get 12 too
and frankly the soldiers were less than
some of the things we got is that right
so
I said these are the 12 things we want
but we immediately won 28 000 free
soldiers
and everybody in the room left
playing games they left
and I said you'll give it to us they
said no we won't be able to give that to
you sir 28 000 free soldiers they said
yes you will you give it I don't even
know what I mean no we want I said okay
here's the story this was on a Friday on
I said on Monday morning
everything that Mexico sells into the
United States will have a 25 percent
tariff place on it including the 32
percent of the car business that you
stole up here's more of the tariffs
Trump still doesn't understand
and this representative who is a very
good man looked at me and said sir
perhaps you misunderstood me we would
love to provide you with 28 000. so this
is true that's true doc Ronnie
we would love to provide you with those
soldiers and we did that's why we had
such good numbers we had 28 000 soldiers
Mexican soldiers on our border
border wall and the water wall was
really a big reason the border wall and
the soldiers that our numbers were the
best in the history of our country and
they were only going to get better if
they just left it alone they're only
going to get better if elected cars that
would make the worst border crisis in
our history
it'd be worse than it is now I don't
know how the hell we're saying that
but maybe they can make it worse I don't
know Rochelle Garza is also a sworn
enemy of election Trump doesn't
understand tariffs but neither does
anybody in the audience so it's sort of
like a wash the state of Texas and if
that happens there will never be another
Republican president in the history of
our country it won't happen good they
won't give it up they will cheat they
will steal and they will rob it and
they're not going to give it up so we
can't let that happen so unless you want
to destroy Texas and America get out and
vote for Ken Paxton Ken come here come
on
he's a good man
[Applause]
hey so Mr President Dan Patrick and I
were over here asking how does this
President draw a crowd year after year
thousands of people unlike anybody we've
ever seen and because it's a cult figure
it out
and and the the question I thought was
well maybe it's he's a great speaker
well Mr President that's true you are a
great speaker but I don't think that's
why everybody's here no is it because
he's a great businessman he clearly is a
great businessman but I don't think
that's why everybody's here maybe it's
because you're a great golfer I don't
think that's why everybody's here
this President and the people that come
to see him are here because in my
opinion you tell me I'm right he's done
more for the American people than any
president in our lifetime remember if so
first of all the crowd's there because
it's a cult and also the people who are
called up they have to suck up to Trump
if they don't kiss Trump's ass he gets
bored however I have one suggestion
because it sounds like there might be a
possibility that he's running for
president again
okay
one suggestion he's got a great slogan a
great theme make America great again but
if he's gonna run again maybe a little
tweak could be
instead of make America great again make
America Texas what do you think
oh God
there's a big sucking noise I can hear
guys get out and vote for Ken he's great
you can't have you can't have these
lunatics get into office they'll never
leave they'll never leave we're also
joined by another friend of mine Texas
agriculture commissioner Sid Miller he's
great stand up yeah he was on television
before the last campaign they said Texas
is going to be close you know why they
do that they say it's going to be close
because if they can cheat enough to win
the people don't go crazy but he said I
don't know where you come from but I
come from Texas Texas will not be close
it's going to be a landslide for Trump
and he turned out to be it was one of
the closest Republican wins in Texas in
40 years it is fantastic guys we have
members of Congress these are friends of
mine they've been through the wars with
me and they're incredible Pat Fallon pat
pat thank you thank you Pat
great guy too Michael Cloud Michael
Michael thank you Michael beautiful
family Michael
a man that I love this guy I didn't know
was he a better Admiral doctor
or Congressman politician
I'm not sure I still I think I think he
was better actually at being a doctor
because he said he was so healthy you
know
but he said I could lose a couple of
pounds and I didn't like him for that I
said don't say that I don't want you to
say that that made me very angry but
that was okay he meant it unfortunately
he meant it
but Ronnie Jackson is an incredible guy
an incredible man and a great doctor too
I'll tell you great at everything highly
respected Admiral doctor and Congressman
how many people can say that
which uh which label do you like best if
they call you a label do you like Mr
Congressman dealer what do you like
he likes Admiral let's call him Admiral
from now on
and a man that a little bit reminds me
another tough cookie this guy's great it
has become a great friend of mine he
wrote a very successful book talking
about the election fraud and he didn't
hold back and he never does he's a real
patriot who loves this state very much
in our country Troy Nels Troy thank you
very much he's tough cookie he's a tough
one right Ronnie good and we love him
thank you the next congressman from
Texas is 38th congressional district
Wesley hunt yeah for people wondering
Trump's been going about 77 minutes an
hour and 17 minutes uh oftentimes you
know we ask is it going to go longer
than 90 minutes or not quite 90 minutes
I think today we could be looking at
140. and Queen
Ryan where's Ryan
thank you Ryan
and somebody that's been fighting
election fraud right from the beginning
Steve Toth where's Steve Steve great job
Senate candidates estate Senate Peter
Flores Kevin Sparks and you know
this person maze Middleton whiz maze
this person very good good job you're
doing a good job
State Senate candidates Adam hinoja
and I'm giving you my complete and total
endorsement Adam we didn't get it out
yet Adam has my complete and total
endorsement
and it was approved by Dan Patrick so
how bad can that be right
good Dan Republican thank you very much
Adam good luck I I hear you're doing
great Republican nominee
and you know that uh
this is a great person County Judge
Connie Scott West County
great
and Connie also
so you have my complete and total
industry okay
tonight only one night only
and the great Sheriff I just read him
and his Incredible family Sheriff J.C
Hooper
thank you sir great job Central Casting
he's Central always risky the names and
then Bob Jones has been so good to us
he's been so great Bob Jones of the Bob
Jones Show in Corpus Christi Bob Joe
advertising in history
there's never been a man that brought
ads at a better price than this guy
pillow I'm not sure how much money I
never saw so many ads
he makes great product at all that stuff
but even more important to me I want him
to buy my Edge if he bought my ads I
could get 17 times more ads for the buck
he's the greatest purchaser of
advertising in history Mike Lindell
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines over 54 countries
have now been taken by the machines
foreign
they took his phone you know that the
FBI pulled him they take bikes they
pulled them aside give us your phone we
want that phone right now give us your
phone it's disgusting if you want the
full story from Mike Lindell check out
my interview with him 30 minutes about
uh 10 days ago
better than I do I swear he looks better
than I do Bob Batterson where's Bob
where's Bob
he looks better than Trump
I didn't think he was a day over 99 I
swear it's 101.
no he looks great thank you very much
Bob incredible when Republicans take
back Congress this November we'll fight
for the people of Texas and we will win
for the people of Texas we promise you
all of us we promise you right
one of the first things we must do is
stand up for parents rights and we'll
get the critical race Theory out of our
schools get it out of our military I had
it out of our military had it out of our
schools and they came in the first day
they signed an executive order putting
it back we'll get it out of every part
of our federal state and local
governments and at long last every
parent in America must be empowered to
opt out of the forced indoctrination in
the classroom and send their child to
the public private Charter religious or
home school they're going to do the
transline now
we will also keep men out of women's
sports does that make sense
oh boy
that's so bad you know my people keep
saying these are people that get paid
too much money they keep saying sure I
don't think you should talk us up
politically correct they said keeping
men out of women's sports
and you know I tell the story I don't
know if anybody heard it probably did
should I or not should I tell it or not
oh no no no no all right so some but you
know I talk about the swimmer who we met
she's beautiful lovely great swimmer and
she she fought very hard years and years
of competition she wants to break the
record of the United States and she's uh
in a meet 1 16 of a second that's what
she has to 1 16 of a second
and she's going to do it and she works
so hard and the meat came and it was
great Fanfare her parents were there
everybody was there they were all
rooting first he's really talented
really good
and she stood up at the blocks and she's
ready to go but she looked down to the
left and she saw her about six young
ladies that she's been competing against
since before high school
recognized all of them said hello hi
good luck then she looked down to the
right and she saw a few people and then
she saw this giant
standing right next with a wingspan
somewhat larger than Wilt the star
Chamberlain
he was a giant
and she said to herself I don't
recognize her
this was the largest
this was the largest woman he had ever
seen
he
had never seen anything quite like it
but she didn't know but you know because
of the fact she's never heard of this
person she figured she can't swim very
well so she wasn't concerned at the size
you know sizes and everything right
so the meat started and it was a
horrible thing happened you probably
heard right she was badly injured during
the meet because the person on her right
this giant person
they actually and believe it or not this
is acceptable it was a
woman in a man's body they call they say
this can you believe I'm saying this but
they think this is acceptable I don't
know but basically this woman in a man's
body this is horrible went by her so
fast she was so badly hurt that the wind
burned was horrible she was hurt
she suffered atrocious wind burn because
isn't this guy the worst that she's
never quite experienced
and he beat the record she wanted to
Beat It by 1 8 of a second
the person to her right Beat It by 38
seconds
38 seconds
and the better story is the weightlifter
a young woman lifting into it lifting
and lifting and these he was gonna break
the record United States record I don't
know what the number was but let's say
it was about 212 pounds she was gonna
lift
212 pounds over it that's a lot
you think I could lift 212 pounds over
my head I don't know I don't know
I don't know they say do it yeah give me
bring some weights up here
212 pounds since he got up and she went
oh I'm gonna do it mom did I'm so proud
of you being here thank you very much
we're going to do it we're going to do
it she got up and you know they put an
eighth of an ounce on one side an eighth
of an ounce of the other these big
barbells and she got it up okay
ah
didn't work okay I don't have to go
through the whole thing right
[Applause]
and then this is
young lady came up
who was a young gentleman a short time
before
and he walks up to the barbells I said
have you lifted before no not much
I would love for them to bring away
stuff
he wins he could have lifted about 150
pounds more over his head let's see
what's going on in our country and do
you know how bad that is for women that
disrespects women that disrespects women
right okay and when they tell me it's
Politically Incorrect please don't speak
about it I'm going to speak about it and
I think the people here and the people
in Texas want to speak about it it's the
most important issue really
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children
without parental consent
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican Congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to restore
free speech in America go out and sign
up by the way for truth social hey did
you see the truth social for the last
four days five days was number one over
Tick Tock and Twitter and everything
number one essential
and Twitter and these incredible women
from
North Carolina how many is this tell me
look at these beautiful people they're
rich as hell too you know they're rich
truth social is very quickly heading
towards bankruptcy follow the Trump tour
look at how beautiful they are they are
so let me and you're not supposed to say
that by the way I'm sorry I insulted you
by saying that I hope you'll understand
you know you're not supposed to say a
woman's beautiful anymore that's like
politically totally unacceptable but you
are beautiful so let me ask you what
number is this how many rallies have you
gone to
74.
93 can you believe that
93.
[Applause]
and they're all happily married they
live in beautiful homes so are your
husbands okay with this deal that you're
doing
uh think of that think of that you're
great thank you very much it's an honor
it's an honor really a great honor thank
you
we'll have a celebration when we break a
hundred right okay
thank you very much it's so great and
everywhere the Republican party has the
chance we must pass critical election
Integrity reforms including Universal
voter ID
citizenship confirmation can you imagine
we'd like to confirm that you're a
citizen we don't want to give you that
there's only one reason they don't
because they cheat otherwise they'd have
no problem with it no more fake drop
boxes no private money pouring into our
local election offices 416 million
dollars from Facebook and ultimately we
need same-day voting you know that no
just all we want is paper ballots the
old-fashioned way that's the way you're
going to stop would you agree with that
Mike that's the way you're going to stop
it
it's the only way
we don't need satellites sending the
signals all over the place somebody
votes let's see I'm going to vote for
Trump I love Trump I'm going to vote for
Chop Trump being being because all over
the world comes back Biden how did that
happen
we're just 17 days away from the most
important midterm election in American
history and we need a landslide so big
that the radical left cannot rig it or
steal it we have to have it big
early voting begins this Monday October
24th but far better than voting by mail
and ballot we don't like mail-in ballots
what you do is you go out and vote on
Election Day it's better and a lot of
people fight me sir supposing there's a
hurricane supposing there's bad weather
well you're just much better off it's
harder to cheat when you do it though
like dogs very stupid so try and look
it's better than not voting but you
don't want to send it in that way you
want to go out on Election Day and just
storm those places what a strange thing
to say you go out out and vote and if
you care about election Integrity
volunteer as an election worker poll
Watcher or Challenger we need you
because they do that they have all these
people a lot of them are thugs you know
a lot of them are hired thugs where they
threaten our people you know that right
we had in Pennsylvania we had thugs
telling people to get the hell out of
here you get out of here and it was
Trump votes by mail by the way this is
the year we're going to take back the
house we're going to take back the
Senate we're going to take back America
and in 2024 most importantly we are
going to take back our magnificent white
house we're going to take it back
together we'll fight for more jobs for
American families all right is he going
to do the Q Anon music is he going to do
it let me know in chat doctor is forging
more products stamped with that
beautiful phrase you know what it is
made in the USA made in the USA it's a
beautiful phrase we'll shut down Biden's
border disaster reinstitute our strong
remain in Mexico policy how about
getting that
remain in Mexico instead of the United
States isn't that nice you think that
was easy no they ended it as soon as
they could and then we won in court but
they want to end it strengthened the
Patriots of ice and Border Patrol and we
will again end Catch and Release we will
end chain migration we will end the Visa
Lottery we will end illegal immigration
once and for a more look once and for
all we're going to end it and you're
going to come into our country you're
going to come in Legally we want people
to come into our country they have to
come in Legally we will stop the crime
wave and democrat-run cities we will
give our police the power they need and
the respect they deserve and we will not
take legal protection away from our
police we want to take they want to take
legal protection so that somebody can
sue a police officer and tell them to go
out and hire a lawyer that's just what
he wants as a lawyer we will restore Law
and Order in America
we will hold China account if you care
about unleashing of that orders upon the
world
we will defend our constitution we will
defend the Second Amendment and we will
proudly uphold the judeo-christian
values and principles of our nation's
father
he means just Christian
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our Great
American flag
always
a great American flag in conclusion our
Maga movement make America great again
remember that make America great again
that's what it stands for
is by far the greatest political
movement in the history of our country
there's never been anything like this
and if I was telling a little FIB they
would have me on the front page of every
newspaper
they've never even challenged the
greatest in history look what we've done
together we're standing up against some
of the most menacing forces entrenched
interests and vicious opponents our
people have ever seen
despite great dangers outside these are
outside dangers that are tremendous our
biggest threat Remains the sick Sinister
and evil people from within our country
but no matter how big or powerful the
corrupt radical left Democrats that we
are fighting against may be
you must never forget this nation does
not belong to them this nation belongs
to you the station belongs to you
this is your home this is your heritage
and our American Liberty is your God
given right another glitch from Houston
to Austin
from Dallas to you might be skipping the
Q music today station to Corpus Christi
and from the Red River to the Rio Grande
the people of Texas live and breathe the
fierce Spirit of Independence
the Lone Star State has always embraced
the cause of American Freedom like no
other like no other
this is the state where William Travis
James Bowie and Davy Crockett the great
baby made their last stand at the Alamo
the beautiful Alamo this is the state
where a small band of Patriots at the
Battle of Gonzales armed with a single
Cannon stared down a foreign army and
declared
come and take it right come and take it
come and take it come on
come and take it
and Texas is the state where generations
of farmers and ranchers sheriffs and
lawmen Cowboys cattle hands Prospectors
Pioneers help build up the greatest
nation in the history of the world
oh no he's doing it
and you already see the cute see the see
these people with the one finger up this
is the cue thing it's like the what
wwg oh my God often security Now goes
through the crowd and tells them to put
their fingers down let's see if it
happens patient that has the highest
inflation in 50 years
and where the stock market finished the
worst first half of the year since
1872. oh God
likewise we are a nation that has the
highest energy costs in its history
we are no longer well yeah someone
someone told the woman with the glasses
to put the finger down we were just too
short years ago
we are a nation that is begging
Venezuela Saudi Arabia
Joe Biden says
yet we have more liquid gold right under
our feet
than any other country
we are a nation that is consumed by the
radical left screen New Deal
yet everyone knows that the green New
Deal will lead to our destruction
we are a nation whose leaders are
demanding everybody knows all electric
cars oh God even though they can't go
far costs too much and whose batteries
are produced in China with materials
only available in China
when an unlimited amount of gasoline is
available inexpensively in the United
States but not available in China
we are a nation that ended oil
exploration and production in the United
States just as the price of oil reached
an all-time high what other country
would do such a thing we are a nation
that surrendered in Afghanistan
leaving behind dead soldiers Americans
this is so stupid I don't know how
anyone could sit through this nonsense
and think this is the guy who should be
our president I mean it's just it's
absurd say the country Ukraine killing
hundreds of thousands of people and it
will only get worse
it would never have happened with me as
your commander-in-chief and for four
straight years it didn't happen and
China with Taiwan
is next
we are a nation that has weaponized its
law enforcement against the opposing
political party like never before we've
got a Federal Bureau of Investigation
that won't allow bad election-changing
facts to be presented to the public
where Hunter Biden's laptop from hell
was a Russian disinformation boy
when the FBI knew and really moving
people to tears as you can see that
refuses to investigate egregious acts of
voting irregularities and fraud
and we have a president who is
cognitively impaired
in no condition to lead our country and
is now casually talking about nuclear
war with Russia which would be World War
III and far more devastating than any of
the previous Wars because of the
Weaponry that no one even wants to think
about
we are a nation that no longer has a
free and fair press fake news is all you
get and they are the enemy of the people
we are a nation where free speech is no
longer allowed where crime is rampant
and out of control
and where more people died of covet in
2021 than in 2020 we are a nation that
is allowing Iran to build a massive
nuclear land
and China to use the trillions of
dollars it has taken from us to build a
military to rival our own
and just two years ago we had Iran China
Russia and North Korea in check they
weren't going to do a thing against us
and everyone knows it they respected the
United States
and perhaps most importantly we are a
nation that is no longer respected or
listened to anywhere around the world
we are a nation that in many ways has
become a joke
true we are a nation that is hostile to
Liberty freedom and faith
we are a nation whose economy is
collapsing into a cesspool of ruin
whose supply chain is broken whose doors
are not stopped whose deliveries are not
coming and whose educational system is
ranked at the bottom of every single
list
we are a nation where large packs of
sadistic criminals packs and thieves are
allowed to go into stores and openly Rob
them beat up and kill their workers and
customers and leave with arm loads of
goods but with no retribution with the
authority of our great police has been
taken with their families and pensions
have been threatened and their lives
would be destroyed for the mere mention
of the words law enforcement
we are a nation where Fentanyl and all
other forms of illegal drugs are easier
to get
then formula for our beautiful little
babies and we're mothers and fathers are
scared with Halloween that their
children will be given deadly drugs like
fentanyl that's not happening there's no
reason to think that's happening it's
another one of those completely crazy
things
crowdedness and if it were happening it
would have nothing to do with Joe Biden
they're notified that the plane won't
leave
and they have no idea when they will
where ticket prices have tripled they
don't have the pilots to fly the planes
they don't have and they've reduced the
size of the little pretzel bags where
you get two pretzels and some crumbs
they're doing
we are a nation that has lost its
confidence willpower and strength we are
a nation that has lost its way but we
are not going to allow this horror to
continue Hara two years ago we were a
great nation and we will soon be a great
nation again
[Music]
he's been speaking for about a minute 40
an hour 42 it's 102 minutes
it was hard-working Patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working Patriots like you who are
going to save our country
we will stand up to the radical left
Democrats he's not going to make it to
two hours I that's a bet I would take
I'm taking the under on two hours you'd
have to be nuts to take the over on two
hours
there is no mountain
we cannot climb there is no Summit we
cannot reach there is no challenge we
cannot meet there is no Victory we
cannot have we will not Bend we will not
break we will not yield
we will never give in we will never give
up and we will never ever back down as
long as we are confident United and
loyal to the cause the tyrants we're
fighting do not stand even a chance
because we are Americans and Americans
kneel to God and to God Alone
uh-huh
[Music]
Trump is half asleep yeah that majority
is back and stronger than ever before my
fellow citizens this incredible journey
we are on together has only just begun
and it is time to start talking about
greatness for our country again we are
one movement one people one family and
one glorious nation under God
so with the help of everyone here today
and citizens all across our land we will
make America powerful America
we will make America wealthy again
we will make America strong again
we will make America proud again
[Applause]
we are keeping you out America safe
again
foreign and we will make America great
again thank you Texas thank you very
much God bless you all thank you
[Music]
There It Is
[Music]
Well another Trump speech essentially
the same speech at every event at this
point in time
and uh it is it is genuinely scary and
you know there's people even in our chat
who come through and they love this
stuff and you know we look at their
comment history and it's completely
delusional and depraved and
um it's it's really bad I mean it is it
is a very serious cult
um difficult to get people out of to
save people from quite frankly
uh they I mean listen
to even fall for this cult in the first
place it's already pretty bad
you're dealing with some pretty it's
pretty low
and once you're in the call then of
course you're going to be extremely
resistant to conceding that you fell for
it
so once you're in it's it's
tough it's very very tough and as you
can see extremely sick people
um and
when people fall for it it is really bad
and listen part of the reason people
fall for it is they're looking for
something they people want something
they know they're they want to make
their lives better etc etc et cetera and
then next thing you know they think
Trump built a wall which Mexico paid for
but Biden took it down but it was never
built but the immigrants been in and out
and stay in Mexico but you know and then
the Griff just keeps going
thank you to S Prez for tidying up our
68 new members to 100 with a gift of 32
subscriptions gifted on twitch
extraordinary
extraordinary we have oh this week by
the way we have two extraordinary live
debates coming for you this week make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube
following on Twitch and and liked on
Facebook Monday night
Ron death santis versus Charlie Crist
Tuesday night Mehmet Oz versus John
fetterman folks folks I will be live for
both of these I don't want you to miss
them
subscribe on YouTube
follow on Twitch like on Facebook
because it's going to be quite a day
quite a day all right see everybody very
soon